hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and in this video I wanna talk about
Delta and how what doesn't happen can be
just as important as what you expect to
happen so before I begin you know a
brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational informational purposes
only you know trading involves risk
don't trade with money you can't afford
to risk now software used in this video
is the order flows trader from order
flows calm it runs on ninjatrader 8 and
yes it is the software that I sell but
you know this video can be applied what
you're gonna learn in here can be
applied if you're using any other
footprint chart I think mine is the best
though alright so what I want to talk
about is something that you know I get
asked quite a bit from traders is you
know Mikey say Delta when Delta is
positive markets generally rise when
markets negative Delta is negative
markets generally sell off why do you
say generally isn't it always right if
Delta means you have aggressive positive
Delta means you have aggressive buyers
shouldn't the market be rallying or you
know if negative Delta implies you have
aggressive sellers in control shoot into
markets be selling off well you know in
trading sometimes the things that don't
happen that you expect to happen let me
rephrase that sometimes the things that
don't happen as expected are just as
important if not more important than
what happens as you expect it so what I
mean by that is here's a market here's
crude oil as a five-minute chart and you
can see we got the swing high up here at
50 to 70 and the market is starting to
sell off right we got four candles in
here with positive Delta as the market
keeps trading lower you see positive 3 3
6 positive 82 positive 96 positive 5 58
and you're thinking why are we going
down you know we got positive Delta the
market should be rallying aggressive
buyers are in control now you know in
all my previous videos when I talk about
deltas and generally well the question
is you're gonna add people will say is
you know why is this market going down
why do I get red candles with positive
Delta well the reason why is because
early on in the candles generally you
have strong passive sellers that the
aggressive buyers were buying from
you see up here 110 192 you see the
offer side is obviously heavier than the
bid side right that's why you got
positive Delta 96 same thing the here
you got a big seller in here 611 that
just stands out you know 346 298 you
know these are strong volumes but the
one that really sticks out is this 305
right here there's buying imbalance you
got positive Delta 558 obviously this
305 contributed quite a lot to it but
what is causing this is you have passive
sellers right you know we tend to think
only in what's the aggressor doing in
the market you know people that are
buying the offer or selling the bid you
know those are the aggressive traders
but there's times where passive sellers
have a lot of inventory and they're
gonna be offering it out to absorb all
the aggressive but in this case the
aggressive buyers you know everyone you
know this market sells off over a two
bar starts rallying but you have passive
sellers up in here with a lot of supply
happy to offer it out you know to absorb
all the aggressive buying that's coming
in finally these aggressive buyers are
tired market drifts down market rips
down you see the crass aggressive
sellers are sorry the passive sellers in
here offering it out for the aggressive
buyers you know the aggressive buyers
can only buy so much before you know
they got no more bullets left but you
know the big sellers right the ones that
gonna put their put a cap on the market
put their foot on the neck at the market
are offering it outright they're gonna
offer it down you know that the the big
producers or the big commercials they
don't just go in and willy-nilly hit all
the bids you know they offer it out they
know they're trying to get good prices
you know they they've got a lot of
inventory at you know that they probably
sitting on from much lower prices
they're happy to sell it here at 50 to
50 they're happy to let all the
aggressive buyers buy it they're happy
to sell it here is 50 to 45 you know
they don't have to go in and whack it
all the way down you know that their
view is so long-term that you know
they're not so price sensitive as
opposed to a short term trader that you
know is probably you know trading you
know within 15 20 ticks of where we are
right now you know these guys that their
entry could be you know five dollars
away ten dollars away
so what's causing this positive Delta is
the supply in there you know the passive
sellers offering out a lot of supply
that the aggressive buyers are buying
from but the passive sellers are
absorbing it now you know there's going
to be instances when a market is
rallying on negative Delta where was it
here so I think it was wrong one here
120 right you got a couple red bars
right negative Delta yet the markets
going higher Mike what's going on you
know red bars market should be trading
lower negative Delta the market should
be trading lower right you see these
bars here okay you know negative Delta
red bars markets going down here you got
marking going up on red bars now granted
this is a five-minute chart five-minute
chart you know any time based chart is
based on time it's it's not a rotational
chart like say a range based chart or a
tick based chart or a point in Figure
reversal chart so you know right up
after 5 minutes boom the bar closes a
new bar starts up but what's happening
in here all right you got negative Delta
67 negative Delta 93 this time you have
passive buyers you know people happy to
work bids to support the market you can
see here there's 304 is probably kicked
off this positive Delta of sorry this
negative Delta of 67
there was a strong bidder here to absorb
all the selling that was coming in you
know as the smart gonna start rallying
up someone's bidding it you know the
people are hitting this bid
this guy's happy to sit here you know
boom you know bar closes start trading
higher you got more passive buyers look
at the the bid side versus the offer
side you know just roughly you know 106
against 99 147 gets 111 206 against 176
139 against 102 it's a little hard to
see there and you open it up but you can
see all the volume majority what's on
the bit side 320 versus 225 188 157 139
102 you know at each price level you
have stronger supportive buying then
resistance selling you know passive
buyers here are more holding up this
market I don't wanna say driving this
market but you know they're bidding here
they're happy to bid here at these
prices and let the aggressive sellers
sell into them that's why you got the
negative Delta right finally these
tellers are just tired you know the the
aggressive sellers got no more bullets
in their guns so to speak and then what
happens to the market it just just just
down and then boom you know the
aggressive buyers you can see here you
know I don't know if these passive
buyers got aggressive also and start
lifting these offers you can see it's
very thinly traded in here but what's
supporting this market is the passive
buying so you know it's it's more of an
advanced concept in in order flow you
sort of got your get your head around
it's a little bit hard to explain
sometimes but you know watch what
happens in the market with the Delta you
know if you're seeing negative Delta on
a rising market pay very close attention
to it because what you're seeing is
supportive buying in the market you know
when you see negative Delta in a rising
market again pay attention to it it's
what doesn't happen as expected that is
you know going to be very important for
you you know if a market is falling on
positive Delta what's causing it you
know ask yourself I mean these are
questions you should ask yourself you
know most traders they just want to have
an indicator say buy here sell there you
know that's you know that's not trading
that's just following you know something
else you know as this trader you know
you're gonna get your best trades by
analyzing the market and saying aha yes
I understand what's going on I
understand why this market is rallying
now on negative Delta because I have
supported buying just as you know
earlier where was it here you know why
this market is selling off you know if I
see this big imbalance up here big
positive Delta on a red candle you
notice even the next bar where we do we
rallied up all right is the root candle
5-minute charge so this bar opened up
here rallied up where to do rallied
right up to that level couldn't get past
that level again that's a nice bearish
sign what the market do boom it reacted
came off close a little bit lower next
bar doesn't even get anywhere close up
here and then just sold off you know
this was a nice move from basically
52-34 he held basically down to 52 bucks
you know there's a nice 20 cents to be
had out of that
that move so again you know thanks for
watching this video if you're interested
in my software obviously just go to my
website so anyway have a great day
everyone
bye bye